[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département est aujourd'hui mercredi
26 avril parole à julien le cam le
secrétaire régional adjoint du syndicat
alliance police nationale nous évoquons
avec lui l'hommage national rendu hier
au policier tué sur les champs elysées
nous verrons aussi quels sont les moyens
humains et matériels nécessaires et qui
doivent être mises en place pour lutter
contre les violences à l'encontre des
forces de l'ordre paroles aussi dans
cette émission un tout autre sujet
parole à deux membres du projet ça un
projet porté par des étudiantes de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines et qui a pour objectif de
favoriser l'insertion sociale des
réfugiés grâce à la culture et à travers
notamment la visite de monuments
historiques c'est une liste qui
malheureusement s'allonge tristement
depuis janvier 2015 six policiers ont
été tués sur le sol français par des
attaques terroristes la dernière en date
bien sûr celle des champs elysées hier
un hommage national a été rendu à xavier
juge les devants notamment les deux
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
julien le cam bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
membre je le disais du syndicat de la
police nationale alliance secrétaire
régional adjoint
hier comment vous avez vécu ce nouvel
hommage malheureusement on dit nouvelle
puisque je le disais si policiers tués
depuis janvier 2015 vous étiez en colère
vous étiez triste vous étiez stoïque
peut-être aussi tout d'abord c'est le
recueillement et le deuil
on a forcément une pensée pour la
famille de xavier pour son compagnon
etienne voilà pour les deux collègues
également qu'ils ont été blessés lors de
l'attaqué l'arrêt de terroristes et on a
forcément une pensée pour nos collègues
de la compagnie d'intervention la 32e
compagnie d'intervention de paris qu'ils
font quand il ya un travail remarquable
effectivement hier on a eu un hommage
très émouvant
ouais rempli de messages de paix
d'union c'est ça aussi la priorité
aujourd'hui dans we sa société un peu
tendu oui alors il faut savoir également
que les forces de l'ordre
il ya un sentiment de colère également
qui monte
passé ce moment de deuil et de
recueillement tout de suite on a un
sentiment de colère
les forces de police qui paye encore un
lourd tribut en pour la défense de la
république voilà on attend que nos
politiques et en attend effectivement
beaucoup de mesures pour aider les
forces de l'ordre
justement dans un communiqué de presse
votre syndic a indiqué je cite qu'il
faut prendre en compte deux des mesures
exceptionnelles afin d'éradiquer toute
forme de violence contre les formes de
police et les forces de police
ces mesures c'est quoi c'est plus
d'hommes plus de matériel c'est quoi la
plus rien évidemment j'ai une faute et
il nous faut des moyens humains même cu
quelques efforts il faut savoir que nous
sur le 78 tu ne montes plus de 300
fonctionnaires
actuellement on est en train de fermer
des unités et des commissariats on ferme
le commissariat de vélizy par exemple
pour le 78 ce qui est complètement
incompréhensible dans le contexte actuel
dans le dans le dans le contexte actuel
à 2,2 de plan vigipirate renforcé chez
nous on restructure
voilà vous avez le sentiment aujourd'hui
clairement d'être d'être à donner
exactement voilà on attend enfin un
ministre de l'intérieur qui nous aide
qui prennent des décisions actuellement
on change de ministre de l'intérieur
tous tous les trois mois
voilà donc on attendait des mesures et
des réformes profondes de la police
parce que les collègues mes collègues
sont épuisés sur le terrain il ya il ya
un malaise aussi un peu plus profond des
policiers sur leur place dans la société
il ya peut-être un manque de
reconnaissance même des citoyens de tous
les jours un temps adulé pendant après
charlie hebdo
et puis un temps souvent crié huer par
oui on est jeté en pâture quand on voit
la ferté au tout de suite
certains politiques vont tirer la
couverture sur eux en jetant en pâture
la police
c'est vrai que là depuis jeudi beaucoup
de gens nous apporte quand même beaucoup
de deux témoignages de soutien ce qui
nous fait ce qui ce qui fait plaisir aux
collègues
sauf qu'on attend vraiment du geste fort
c'est à dire des renforts de policiers
des renforts des des moyens
supplémentaires
on attend et xav plusieurs réformes et
notamment une réforme de la procédure
pénale la procédure pénale c'est à dire
c'est à dire alléger la procédure
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut savoir également
mes collègues de terrain souffre de
moyens mais mes collègues en
investigation souffre de cette loser
lourdeur de la procédure pénale
faut savoir qu'avec le manque
d'effectifs les dossiers s'accumulent et
mes collègues n'en peuvent plus il faut
surtout également que le prochain
président de la république mette fin
président ou présidente mettre fin à
cette politique du chiffre dans la
police nationale est-ce que faut aussi
envisager et porter une réflexion plus
large et plus concrètes sur les missions
de la police
on parle beaucoup de tâches
administratives qui ne devrait pas être
faite par part vous est certainement
imaginé par des citoyens c'est le cas je
crois en angleterre il ya des citoyens
qui font des certaines tâches
administratives
est-ce que ça mais là depuis bien
plusieurs semaines mes collègues doivent
s'occuper des des procurations
électorale il ya plusieurs
fonctionnaires qui sont mobilisés chaque
jour dans les commissariats actuellement
pour s'occuper des des procurations
électorale ce n'est pas notre rôle
on a recentré le policier au coeur de
son métier il faut savoir qu'on a trop
de tâches indues
nous avons plusieurs policiers sur le
département qui gardent des
personnalités politiques on n'a rien à
faire à garder ces sétois par exemple de
la sécurité privée est exactement les
gares de l'est guère d'hôpital ce n'est
pas aux policiers d'effectuer un on doit
garder les détenus dans les hôpitaux
sachant que nous c'est des patrouilles
en moins sur la voie publique pour
justement sécuriser la voie publique et
à aider les gens alors vous parliez tout
à l'heure de la présidentielle
évidemment deux candidats en course
marine le pen emmanuel macron tous deux
souhaitent la création de postes 15000
pour marine le pen emmanuel vacon 10000
forcément ça va dans le sens souhaité
oui alors j'espère que ces annonces
seront suivis d'actes parce que nous on
nous promet beaucoup de choses ça fait
des mois qu'on nous promet justement les
annonces de nos précédents ministres de
recentrer le policier au coeur de son
métier nous dans le 78 rien n'a été fait
on a gagné là il faut savoir que sur la
dernière promotion de gardiens de la
paix on a eu six affectation pour le 78
je dérange loi ces manifestations par
exemple à bois d'arcy sur la situation
voilà donc il faut savoir qu'on a un
contexte on a des zones de sécurité
prioritaire on a des idées spe dans le
78 on a besoin d'effectifs pour
justement assurer la sécurité des gens
dont on y y on n'a pas assez de
policiers dans les yvelines
dernière question sur le plan qui était
présenté par le gouvernement c'était en
octobre 2016 plus de moyens matériels
notamment des gilets pare-balles des
armes le renouvellement des voitures est
ce que avec les aucun manque de moyens
aujourd'hui vous voyez rien arriver sur
le département d un homme fort qui a été
fait est évident
effectivement au niveau du plan bac mais
il faut savoir que mes collègues qui
sont en police-secours les primes aux
intervenants n'ont pas eu de moyens
justement de défense intermédiaires on
manque de casques balistique de
boucliers balistiques
il faut savoir que les primes en
intervenant sur des cas d'attentât ce
sont mes collègues de la police secours
nous on n'a rien vu venir on nous avons
pas de véhicules supplémentaires et
l'autre jour on a visité avec avec donc
le tout le secrétariat du chsct on a
fait une visite de site sur saint
germain en laye il faut savoir qu'un
intérieur du commissariat ça fait 30 ans
qu'il n'ya aucuns travaux d'effectuer
donc les locaux se délabre il faut
savoir voilà qui ajoute au sentiment un
peu d'abandons exactement moi j'ai mes
collègues par exemple sur trapèze en
cours qui travaillent dans des
conditions d'hygiène déplorables
il ya des rails allait présence de
cafards c'est honteux ça va bien merci
pour cette mise au point julien lecat
merci d'être venus en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
régional adjoint du syndicat alliance
police nationale
[Musique]
et on poursuit cette émission avec un
tout autre sujet manon to retain et
mathilde de théron bonsoir vous êtes
respectivement responsable
communications et partenariats pour le
projet à ça ça ça veut dire smile again
up games ce projet vous le conduisait
dans le cadre de vos études en master 2
à lui vs qu est celui ci a pour but de
favoriser l'insertion sociale des
réfugiés grâce à la culture
c'est un vaste projet déjà est ce que
l'une d'entre vous peut nous expliquer
d'où vient l'histoire de ce projet
comment vous en êtes venu à à penser à
ça comme vous l'avez dit on fait partie
donc de l'hiver est ce qu on qu'on est
en master en fait qualité et relation
client et donc dans le cadre de ce
masters on a un projet humanitaire et
sociale à faire et donc chaque année
c'est sur une cible entre guillemets
différentes donc que l'année dernière
c'était les sdf l'année d'avant c'était
prisonniers et cette année on s'est dit
que les réfugiés c'était vraiment une
cible qui nous tenait à coeur parce
qu'on en entend vraiment beaucoup parler
dans l'actualité et voilà on s'est dit
tiens comment on va pouvoir les aider
et donc c'est là c'est là que les
parties le projet en fait et pourquoi
cet aspect culturel auquel on pense pas
souvent quand on parle d'insertion on
peut penser au travail au logement et
vous avez pris l'aspect culturel plutôt
original pourquoi justement je pense
qu'on a voulu montrer un avoir un regard
différent sur ces réfugiés six migrants
qui arrivent en france
et du coup lui un peu dé stigmatiser on
a voulu un peu créer une sorte de
réinsertion sociale à travers la culture
qui nous a semblé primordial et aussi un
peu ludique par les sorties qu'on a vus
proposer concrètement justement gérer
vos poser la question quand on parle
d'insertion par la culture qu'est ce que
vous faites quelles actions vous menez
alors des sorties ce qu'il ya autre
chose
il ya des cours je crois savoir où des
cours vous aider en tout cas pour des
cours de français non partenariat avec
nous
pour catholique de versailles on a on a
fait une récolte de matériel de
scolaires pour la réalisation de cours
de français langue étrangère en fait
donc on a récolté tout ce qui était
cahiers stylos des lecteurs cd etc
vous avez du coup organiser des sorties
on en a vu des images à la tour eiffel
aussi au château de versailles c'est
bientôt où ça a été passé le sera le 21
juin prochain le 21 juin au château de
versailles
quelles sont les réactions de ces
réfugiés quand quand il découvre par
exemple la tour eiffel quand ils m'ont
tout en haut de la tour eiffel je pense
que quand on pense que pour eux ça a été
vraiment une super après midi enfin
c'est vraiment ça leur a vraiment plu
puisque il y en a certains qui nous ont
confié que c'était vraiment leur rêve de
monter à la tour eiffel en arrivant sur
paris il voyait le monument de loin mais
il n'était jamais montée donc c'était
vraiment on a vraiment eu que des
retours positifs puis pour vous je
réagis devions avoir un sentiment de
satisfaction de mener une bonne action
c'est ça va là après on a un compte
facebook en fait sur lesquels on partage
beaucoup nos actions et là on a certains
réfugiés qu'ils nous ont mis des
commentaires merci beaucoup c'est génial
ce que vous faites pour nous et du coup
ça c'est vraiment enrichissant pour nous
et motivant pour la suite en fait
expliquez-nous comment on comment vous
travaillez j'imagine que les réfugiés
vous ne les connaissez pas
personnellement
du coup c'est avec les associations
locales comment ça se passe concrètement
bas pour 7 s pour cette section de la
sortie au sommet de la tour eiffel et
pour l'open bus aussi qu'on a fait dans
paris on travaille avec une association
de versailles qui s'appelle welcome 78
donc qui aident à placer les réfugiés
dans des familles d'accueil d'île de
france
il ya un vrai intérêt pour votre
démarche les autres associations sont
tout de suite intéressé peut-être vous
avez eu des contacts avec des personnes
il ya une vraie est un vrai intérêt vous
sentez que c'est facile de mettre ça en
place
ou alors quand même c'est difficile et
il ya beaucoup de deux problèmes de
barrage face à vous un envoyé pas mal
gmail au début même pour trouver des
associations avec lesquelles travailler
mais après une fois excellent c'est
vraiment tout s'est enchaîné en fait
expliqué nous et parler nous peut-être
dans notre volet de votre projet c'est
de lutter contre les préjugés à travers
les photos
que vous pouvez m'expliquer ça oui donc
on est en train de préparer une
exposition à la bibliothèque
universitaire de saint quentin
donkey qui va qui exposera en fait
plusieurs clichés qui ont été pris lors
de nos sorties à la tour eiffel et en
open bus dans paris
justement parce qu'en fait on était si
on était accompagné d'un photographe
lors de ces actions du coup pour nous
l'objectif c'est aussi de sensibiliser
les étudiants à notre projet et à la
cause des réfugiés ça c'était vraiment
un taux important de du projet ça et du
coup vous voulez mettre l'accent sur
cette action est alors derrière question
justement vos collègues du masters les
enseignants qu'est-ce qui vous disaient
sur le tir debout et vous encouragez vos
pouces comment ça se passe c'est assez
original assez important ce que vous
faites notamment à votre âge vous êtes
encore étudiante j'imagine que forcément
vous en dit que du bien
on a des retours très positifs ils
soutiennent et c'est vraiment cette si
on sait que si on veut plus
d'information on se rend sur la page
facebook du projet ça merci à vous
d'être venu merci julien le cam aussi
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités
pour ce soir prochain rendez vous demain
d'ici là retrouvez toutes nos séquences
en replay sur tv fil 78 points comme ou
l'application et tv fil 78 excellente
soirée à tous
[Musique]